so Hillary Clinton has now joined the
Jill Stein quixotic recount effort in
swing states including Wisconsin
Pennsylvania in Michigan campaign
Council mark Elias announced that while
the Clinton campaign had no evidence of
hacked voting systems they wanted to
ensure the veracity of the vote quote
because we had not uncovered any
actionable evidence of hacking or
outside attempts to alter the voting
technology we had not planned to
exercise this option ourselves but now
that a recount has been initiated in
Wisconsin we intend to participate in
order to ensure the process proceeds in
a manner that is fair to all sides
unquote Stein is infamously launching
the recount effort if you missed it in
an obvious effort to raise money for the
Green Party so what's the goal here well
not to overturn election results clearly
because Hillary lost but Ron Fournier of
National Journal raises another awful
horrifying possibility quote raising
doubts about the legitimacy of the
election even without overturning the
results as part of Clinton's plans to
keep her options open for 2020 make some
calls you'll hear the same from her
confidants
except this would actually be the
best-case scenario for Republicans
hillary was a historically bad candidate
she was the first female major party
candidate in history and she was somehow
unable to beat the guy who was caught on
tape talking about grabbing woman by the
bleep
her husband was a president with
significant blue-collar appeal she lost
the blue collar white vote in historic
fashion she and even matched Barack
Obama's numbers among Hispanics after
Trump openly said a judge of Mexican
descent couldn't judge his case fairly
she relied on Hollywood glitz rather
than on-the-ground campaigning and she
paid for it with the White House
Hillary for re-election in 2020 would be
incredible for Republicans who'd be so
great she'd be back she'd be twice as
annoying which is almost mathematically
impossible
she'd have half the enthusiasm again
almost mathematically impossible and she
doesn't have the energy level which
means that she would be twice as dead
meanwhile she would suck all of the
oxygen out of the room preventing other
candidates from rising her corruption
would ensure any future Trump corruption
would be negated as a campaign issue
Republicans should pray for more Hillary
Clinton in a way though Hillary doesn't
really have much of a choice
donations to the Clinton Foundation of
plummeted since her loss since there's
no pay if there's no pay for play what
happens to her if she merely becomes a
failed presidential candidate Hillary
needs access in order to sell the access
so watch for a Hillary comeback we can
only
hope and pray that once again Hillary's
ego drives her to new lows I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
okay so much to get to today on this
post a Thanksgiving Day show we're back
and we're kind of in the nice period of
the year this is this period between
Thanksgiving in New Year's where
everybody calms down a little bit we
comb them all the way up till the
inauguration except for the continuing
chaos that emerges from the left and
from the White House on a consistent
basis so we'll keep you up-to-date on
all of that but first we say hello to
our advertisers over at lyft so if you
are in need of a ride somewhere and you
don't want to get in a car driven by an
insane person
or you don't want to get into a cab
because they're very expensive lyft is
the best ride-sharing app there is right
now if you go to lift and you download
their app if you enter promo code
Shapiro's you get up to ten dollars off
three free rides so you get you got ten
dollars three fries thirty bucks
in case you couldn't do the math if you
download that free lyft app today and
you enter the promo code chip here on
the payment section you get that 30
dollar value for free which is awesome
promo code Shapiro so I use lyft my wife
uses left that's important to me because
my wife works all hours she's constantly
coming home very late at night after
taking care of people in the ER and
sometimes she actually has to come home
on Shabbos just to come home on
Saturdays because she's a doctor which
means that an emergency situations she's
allowed to work but she uses rideshare
apps because you're really not supposed
to drive so instead she uses lyft to get
home and and the and that's the that's
the best way to do it the best way to do
it is lift it again safest drivers
they've the best capacity for taking you
in a safe way
lyft is the place to be so go get that
app right now and use promo code Shapiro
$30 value for free alrighty so there are
some good news over the weekend some
really good news over the weekend an
evil piece of crap died so that's always
excellent Fidel Castro bit the bullet 90
years too late I shouldn't say that
maybe who's a good child I don't know
but but certainly about 60 years too
late he took over Cuba at age 32 so any
time before that it could have gone that
I've been alright he did an enormous
amount of damage to people the media
have treated him as though he was a
controversial figure as opposed to a
mass murdering barbaric dictator he was
basically low-rent Stalin for people who
don't know much about Fidel Castro and I
want to go through and talk a little bit
about what Fidel Castro actually did
because the left will never tell you
straight exactly what was wrong with
Fidel Castro because the thing about
Fidel Castro for the left is the left is
pretty much fine the left is pretty much
ok with anything that that will that
other leftist to do they they're not in
love with the mass murder but if mass
murder has to get done in order to
create the new utopia they can live with
it so the front page of the New York
Times said a revolutionary who defied
the US and held Cuba in his thrall well
he didn't actually hold Cuba in his
thrall he actually created a giant gulag
and sentenced everybody in the country
to stay in it and he wasn't a
revolutionary so much as he was a
socialist dictator who murdered all
dissidents but I think that it's
important to go through some of the
facts about about Fidel Castro so we
will do that today so first of all Fidel
Castro took over the country in 1959 he
took over from a guy named general
Batista general Batista was also a
dictator but he was sort of a right-wing
dictator and general Batista under
Batista Cuba was one of the richest
countries in Latin America it was on the
upswing and sort of like not a good guy
Bautista but sort of like Pinochet
except less violent he was eventually
gonna end up transitioning into a form
of democracy in all likelihood instead
there's a violent revolution with Castro
and its source and here is Fidel Castro
taking power here's what it looked like
outside Havana's presidential palace
hundreds of thousands rally at the call
of revolutionary leader Fidel Castro who
estimated their number at a million most
of the throng wears the colors of
Castro's 26th of July Movement they are
in an exultant mood
man who overthrew the Batista
dictatorship calls on them to approve
the public trials and executions of pro
Batista figures guilty of war crimes and
atrocities the executions some 250 to
date have been widely criticized by many
as to hasty and summary even if
justified says Castro the Cuban
revolutionary government no reason to
offer explanations to America or to
anyone except the people of Cuba
Gastner asks his audience if it favors
the summary court-martial and gets his
answer in a roar of approval
executing thousands and thousands of
people he conspired with the mass
murderer Che Guevara will talk about che
in just a minute to overthrow Fugazi a
Batista who was that dictator and then
he began a guerrilla campaign resulting
in his takeover of the island
he immediately exiled priests he exiled
all all religious figures he destroyed
religious schools he nationalized all
businesses he imprisoned and murders
murdered his enemies within the first
three months he had between 600 and 1100
people shot che guevara said is a direct
quote from Shea this this piece of crap
who you see people walking around with
his face on t-shirts it's like walking
around again with a solid t-shirt said
to send men to the firing squad judicial
proof is unnecessary is what Che Guevara
said these procedures are in a que ik
boos wha detail this is a revolution and
a revolutionary must become a cold
killing machine motivated by pure hate
we must create a pedagogy of the
paradigm that's the execution law so you
have to teach people through the
execution while Castro actually
imprisoned more of his citizens by
percentage than Hitler or Stalin by 1961
hit imprison to three hundred thousand
human beings he asked the Soviet Union's
actually nuke the United States in 1961
during the Cuban Missile Crisis Castro
supported terrorist groups all over the
world ranging from FARC and Colombia to
Shining Path in Peru and the Sandinistas
in Nicaragua hundreds of thousands of
Cubans fled millions actually many
drowned in the ocean thousands people
drowned in the ocean as they attempted
to sail to Florida between 1959 and 1992
at least two million Cubans fled Cuba
now some of the lies that you'll be told
is that he didn't impoverish q but he
absolutely did the average GDP per
capita in in Cuba when Castro took over
was a little bit over $2,000 per person
per year by 1999 the average GDP per
capita remember there's a forty year
period by 1999 the per capita GDP in the
nation was $2,300 so it advanced $300 in
40 years
according to discover the networks the
average daily wage for agricultural
workers in Cuba in 1958 was 3 bucks the
average daily wage in France at the time
was 2 dollars and 73 cents Cuba had in
1958 the year before Castro took over
the highest standard of living of any
latin-american country and half of
Europe here's the Wall Street Journal
the Cuba that Castro inherited was
developing but relatively
prosperous and ranked third in Latin
America in doctors and dentists and
daily calorie consumption per capita its
infant mortality rate was the lowest in
the region and the 13th lowest in the
world
Cubans were among the most literate
Latins and had a vibrant civic life with
private professional commercial
religious and charitable organizations
Castro destroyed all of it he ruined
agriculture by imposing collective farms
making Cuba dependent first on the
Soviets and later on oil from Hugo
Chavez's Venezuela in the past
half-century Cuba's export growth has
been less than Hades and now even
doctors are scarce because so many are
sent abroad to earn foreign currency
hospitals don't even have sheets or
aspirin the average monthly income is
twenty dollars government food rations
are inadequate as for that healthcare
you always hear about the Cuban
healthcare absolute crap there are three
systems there the socialist
revolutionaries you guy could care there
the foreigners who come and pay with
cash like Fat Michael Moore and then
there is and then there is the actual
people of Cuba this is according to Jane
or blender of national reviews at
hospitals and clinics our crumbling
conditions are so unsanitary patients
may be better off at home whatever home
is if they do have to go to the hospital
they must bring their own bed sheets
soap towels food lightbulbs even toilet
paper that's how poor healthcare is
imagine you go to the hospital and you
have to bring your own light bulbs and
toilet paper
basic medications are scarce doctors
have been known to reuse latex gloves
okay the whole point of latex gloves
that you don't reuse them as for the
infant mortality right they're
constantly bragging about the infant
mortality right that's because they do
all sorts of prenatal checkup so they
want to keep that statistic artificially
high and the way that they do that is
they do prenatal checkups if there's any
danger to the pregnancy at all they
simply abort the kid so the abortion
rates in Cuba are extraordinarily
extraordinarily high it really is a
horrifying system of government and
that's been brought about by the Castros
but look how the media just worshipped
the Castro so this is Ed Sullivan Ed
Sullivan head-on Castro this is 1961 I
believe or 1959 and here's ed Sullivan
who's then the most popular television
host in the United States praising Fidel
Castro
were you a baseball pitcher yes they
were feature basketball basketball act
we keep every every everything evidence
part well undoubtedly all about exercise
you didn't school prepare you for this
role they help leave any bunch of mound
before the fine young man in a very
smart young man with the help of God and
our prayers and with the help the
American government he will come up with
the sort of democracy down there that
America could have he he'll create the
sort of democracy America should have
unbelievable this have a media tree to
Fidel Castro a mass murdering dictator
mass murdering dictator Castro on Face
the Nation here's Castro appearing on
face the nation's from 1959 in Cuba is
now very strong and with a tremendous
force no body is enough powerful now the
public opinion okay so he says the
public opinion holds right this is
always what socialist revolutionaries
would-be dictators say whenever somebody
talks about public opinion making might
right that's never a good thing it's why
demagogues are scary right people who
come up and they say well the public
says I can do this doesn't matter what
the law says doesn't matter what the
Constitution says the people want it
we'll have summary executions again tens
of thousands of people murdered hundreds
of thousands of people imprisoned by
Fidel Castro talking about human rights
three years later he was dead and he
dead because he went into other parts of
Latin America and attempted to lead coos
their communist coos there's he's
talking there about how nobody should
interfere with Cuba and then he promptly
went to Latin America and attempted to
start a revolution in Bolivia and was
killed for his trouble thank God he was
really terrible human being
che Guevara for you want to see what it
was like for Cubans living in Castro's
Cuba people still are by the way thanks
to the incompetence of Barack Obama and
this idiotic policy imposed over the
last 50 years in the United States I've
never been in favor of this policy that
the United States has with regard to
with regard to non assassination it
makes no sense to me I don't see why
literally millions upon millions
generations of people should live in
terror and suffering because we have to
let an old piece of crap like an old
disgusting
desiccated piece of human debris like
Fidel Castro live we wouldn't better off
killing him but but here's here's what
it was like in Cuba and still is like in
Cuba people can't escape it's a giant
prison here's some footage of Cuban
refugees here's what people were doing
just to get out of Castro's Cuba while
all of these Westerners were praising
Cuba as this Halcyon of light and
liberty here is here's what it actually
looked like for people try and get out
in 2003 news media the world over
broadcast this image a dozen Cubans
sailing for freedom aboard an old green
Chevy truck Luis and his three-year-old
son on Hill were on board
Luis explained to me that few new cars
entered Cuba after the Revolution in the
1950s but his old one worked just fine
he tells me he was scared building the
boat in secret and pushing from shore in
the dark of night but he was willing to
risk everything for a better life in
America okay I mean this is again
hundreds of thousands of people
attempting to escape Cuba in the early
1980s there are so many people trying to
escape the Fidel Castro actually said
fine and then he sent a huge number of
kind of the the Cuban criminal class he
let them escape you had all the
criminals go to Miami and that's why he
saw a major upsurge in crime and the
drug trade in Miami in the early part of
the 1980s but people have been
attempting to float in cars I mean this
how you ended up with with the situation
with the was that Gonzalez what was the
name of the the kid who was deported
back to Cuba after his after his dad
died on the way over from or his mother
died on the way over from Cuba and then
he was deported back to Cuba thanks to
the Clinton administration people have
been attempting to get out of Cuba for
for 50 years thanks to the Castro's I
here's some footage of Castro's
prisoners speaking about what it was
like to be a dissident in Castro's Cuba
it was like being in the depths of hell
the suffering made me a little crazy but
my husband and children wrote to me in
that kept me going
she said Cardona husband Hank Hill were
arrested at a small anti-government
demonstration in May 2014 their crime
they say chanting down with Fidel Castro
we're always saying yeah it's like I see
you about a boy request more education
for Cubans has been about fear and how
to be afraid about how to avoid
confrontation with the authorities
because they have power they teach you
what they want you to know but not
really what goes on in the world
he said that girl they lad both were
released on January 8th according to
their prison papers the pair spent eight
months behind bars of what they say were
appalling conditions okay and that's not
unusual
lots of people died and just went
missing in in Castro's prisons Castro
had a special hatred for homosexuals so
very early in his regime he basically
rounded up homosexuals here is testimony
from some gay folks who are rounded up
by Fidel Castro and put in prison camps
when Dominic Mooney that's a la la una
lista de los can be asserted without
program to know even otras when I were
saying gawe Paulo's friend Catherine % e
al exceeded every imaginable in stones
nahi Nablus a la persona person being
purged a year algo okay now here we are
hanging there are people aware and
Porter
but people were shot and killed
themselves as we see that important
think that in continuation if the public
are they were ashamed before the release
to allow me you see unfamiliar class he
had to go home and say some killed
themselves okay that was not uncommon in
Castro's Cuba and again this is somebody
who mass executions were not were not
uncommon in Castro's Cuba here is a
here's a footage of one of the original
executions this was released by the
Castro regime very early on this was a
supposedly a member of Batista's regime
so it's a lightful folks delightful
folks the reason that I do all of this
is because the left in America and in
the West glorified people like Castro
they really do and it's truly disgusting
so first we're gonna give you and we're
gonna have to first let me take a break
real fast and so let's say hello to our
friends over at trunk club so on the
lighter side obviously it's now Black
Friday for Black Friday it's it's Cyber
Monday it's it's the the week of deals
and over at trunk club.com slash been
you go there and you sign up right now
he's the trunk club calm slash Ben and
it's a great gift that you can buy for
yourself you buy it for a family member
what's great about trunk club the way
that this works is that they have all of
these people who are consultants who you
can text with you can you can chat with
then they help you pick out the kind of
clothes that you want and they they help
tailor those clothes make sure that they
fit you properly and then they send you
a trunk of the kind of clothes that
you're looking for you keep what you
want you send back what you don't you
only get a trunk when you're when you
are ordering you know certain types of
clothing so it's not like it just comes
every month and becomes a hassle if you
don't like it you send it right back and
they also have these club houses that
are really great places like Boston and
New York Chicago LA Dallas DC Charleston
they all have these Clubhouse I've been
to the one out in LA it's great actually
meet with a stylist they go through your
wardrobe they tell you exactly what you
need and they help guide you through the
process and all of their stuff is really
beautifully made it's all top brand
stuff it takes you know building a
really good wardrobe takes time and you
should really get top-end items it's
better to get one top-end item there
a bunch of times then it is got a bunch
of crappy items that are gonna fall
apart immediately a trunk club is for
the best quality materials the best
quality stuff it's not a subscription
service you order the clothes whenever
you like from your own stylist you take
five days to try everything on you can
send it back you can ask them for advice
you have their text so you can text back
and forth you can even help pair up the
new clothes with the old clothes over a
trunk club and your stylist is a
professional I've worked with their
professionals they really are top-notch
its trunk club.com slash been trunk club
comm slash been so back to our story the
reactions to the cast for death are
really quite telling the difference
between right and left on the Castro
death is really quite amazing so Donald
Trump gave what I thought is the best
thing that he's done this entire
campaign it's the best thing that I've
done that I think that Donald Trump has
done since he's since he announced here
was Donald Trump's statement on the on
the death of Fidel Castro and he didn't
write this but it doesn't matter he's
the president-elect so he put it out it
says quote today the world marks the
passing of a brutal dictator who
oppressed his own people for nearly six
decades Fidel Castro's legacy is one of
firing squads theft unimaginable
suffering poverty and the denial of
fundamental human rights while Cuba
remains a totalitarian island it is my
hope that today marks a move away from
the horrors endured for so long and
toward a future in which the wonderful
Cuban people finally live in the freedom
they so richly deserve though the
tragedies deaths and pains caused by
Fidel Castro cannot be erased our
administration will do all it can to
ensure the Cuban people can finally
begin their journey to our prosperity
and liberty I joined the many Cuban
Americans who supported me so greatly in
the presidential campaign including the
brigade 2506 Veterans Association that
endorsed me with the hope of one day
soon seeing a free Cuba this is the best
statement that there was from any world
leader on this
that's exactly right Fidel Castro does
not deserve one iota of praise Reince
Priebus came out and he said look you
know Obama's famous deal that he did
with it with the Castro's we'll just
renege on it we're not going to do that
anymore
because that deal is a total train wreck
and everybody knows it and anything that
we can do to get rid of it we will know
there's parts of it that may be very
difficult to to get out of but we're
going to look to a fresh look at it put
fresh eyes on that deal and I can assure
you if anyone can renegotiate that deal
or do something about it
make it better for the American people
and that started nuclear arms race in
the Middle East it's going to be
president-elect Trump
okay so if he if he rips up the Cuba
deal that would be a wonderful thing
obviously Ted Cruz says the Obama
administration has strengthened the
Cuban regime clearly they have
unfortunately the policies of the Obama
administration have made that less
likely what the Obama administration has
done is strengthened Raul Castro Raul is
the dictator now you know I asked my dad
at dinner last night well what do you
think happens now that Fidel is dead and
and he shrugged and said Raul's been in
charge for years that this is the system
has gotten stronger and what Obama has
done is funneled billions of dollars to
Raul Castro which is being used to
oppress dissidents you know in 2015
roughly 10,000 political arrests
occurred in Cuba that is five times as
many as occurred in 2010 when there were
only about 2000 this tyrannical regime
has gotten stronger because of a weak
president weak foreign policy and it is
very much my hope and belief that with a
new president coming into office in
January president Trump and new
administration that that u.s. foreign
policy not just to Cuba but towards our
enemies whether they are Iran or North
Korea will no longer be a policy of
weakness and appeasement but instead
using us strength to force and and press
for change okay so that's the okay so
here is the so so that is the the left
that's the right stake on the Castro
death for more for the left stake and
this is where it really gets interesting
you're gonna have to go to daily wire
calm and subscribe we have to cut off
the live broadcast on Facebook and
YouTube now but if you come a subscriber
at daily wire comm 8 bucks a month gets
you access $8 a month only and if you
become the annual subscriber we're still
giving away my book for free signed
copies of my books religions plus you
get to be part of the mailbag once
you're a subscriber we do a live mailbag
on Thursdays we'll be doing that this
week as we do every week and you get the
rest of the show live as well plus there
are other goodies that are coming soon
if your subscriber also you don't have
to look at the ads on our site the
annoying pop-up ads on our site so daily
wire calm to become a subscriber or go
later and listen to the rest of the show
over at SoundCloud
or iTunes we are the largest
conservative podcast in the United
States
you